[Music]
it's endured one of the world's
strictest lockdowns
in lebanon a month-long 24-hour curfew
has bad most people from leaving their
homes
but protests like this one near beirut
have led to a gradual easing
[Music]
now hospital staff worry the strain on
resources will grow
the good news officials are rolling out
a vaccine campaign
but critics say it's too slow and
perhaps too fragile
in a country where government skepticism
and outright anger continue to grow
[Music]
so can the vaccine turn things round for
lebanon that's a question i'll post to
our guest from beirut in a moment a
clinical psychologist
who's grappling with the issue of
whether to stay in the country or go
like many medical professionals the way
forward for lebanon will not
be easy the country counts a significant
refugee population
including large numbers of palestinians
and even more arrivals from syria
the demographics affect how the pandemic
plays out
a u.n report shows the covert mortality
rate for palestinian refugees in lebanon
is a whopping three times higher than
other groups
coronavirus infections continued to
surge medical capacity has already
stretched to its limits
and with a financial crisis having
crushed the economy half all citizens
now live in poverty
where to turn every bed here
is full staff working around the clock
as they risk their lives to save lives
like their patients here at rafiq hariri
university hospital in beirut
they too are frightened
i see my children every day but every
day i live in fear that i may transmit
this virus to them
i'm trying my best to protect them
the situation has been getting worse
every day
for the last three weeks our icu beds
are full
and we have about 20 patients in the
emergency room
waiting for an empty bed to enter
and this is really is very exhausting
for all our staff
for more than a month the country has
been under a 24 hour a day curfew
to try to tackle the spread of covet 19.
but anti-lockdown protests in cities
like tripoli
put pressure on the government to begin
easing restrictions
and last week ministers began relaxing
some of its lockdown measures
that may help the struggling economy but
it's worrying health workers
the number of infections
in the community is still high we have
more than 20 percent test positivity
rate
and if we prematurely open the country
that will lead to
a reversal of the all the gains that we
have
you know achieved up till now while
patients here
are receiving the best care available a
shortage of medicines is making the job
for health professionals
even tougher the economic crisis
is also forcing some to leave lebanon
altogether
we can see these skilled health workers
at all levels
they are looking forward to leave the
country i don't have exact numbers
but at least i know from a two
prestigious institutions
with their total staff of 230 300
250 physicians like 60 people have
departed
they have left which is a quite
significant number
in the middle of a pandemic hospitals
like this
can't afford to lose a single member of
staff
but with lebanon in crisis they may have
no choice
brigitte is a clinical psychologist and
joins us from beirut
what's your explanation for so many
doctors leaving the country
well several factors of course have
impacted decisions of these
professionals
starting with the devaluation of the
lebanese pound towards the dollar so the
income that they used to make
is you know now peanuts but i think the
biggest decision really came after the
beirut blast in august
when it really hit security and the
security of their families
and some of them they had their clinics
destroyed the hospitals we have several
hospitals that were destroyed
family homes i think this is what pushed
people over the edge and then
they decided to leave unfortunately so
it comes down to
not just the financials but also a
distrust in the government is it
is that also where this distrust comes
from as as far as
taking a vaccine and this distress is
is a minor word actually for what people
feel towards the government
uh but yeah it's it's it's not only at
this just it's a sense of security and
you know security
is really the basis to build on a life
you need to be secure anywhere in order
to be able to
thrive and work and and have a family in
love and
have relationships etc so when this is
not present
and the beirut blast was very difficult
on people because it hit
people in their comfort zones in their
homes
you know people were at home people were
you know visiting others people were in
cafes
so it wasn't you know like there was a
declared war and then you know
shelling started it was just out of the
blues that this
catastrophe happened and it hurts many
people
and when the the security base is shaken
that that hurts a lot so many we have
many doctors
who are young physicians and doctors and
who were starting to establish their
career who left
but we also have very well established
doctors and professionals who've had a
career of 30 40 years
in lebanon who also left so that tells
you how difficult it is pretty much
on everybody uh to be living here well
well
tell me if it does affect everybody what
about you are you going to stay
we've you've just told us about the
financial crisis the bay route blast
now the coronavirus crisis yeah
i'm i mean maybe we're giving it another
year my
husband and family and i and and see
where that goes
it's also very difficult to leave you
know you have to understand our
relationship with lebanon the lebanese
lebanon it's a love-hate relationship
we love the country we want to be here
we want to serve it
we want to build it but sometimes the
country hasn't loved us back
and it's been very difficult and there
comes a point where you need to have a
you know you have to cut this
dysfunctional relationship some people
have done it
to me i find it more difficult but who
knows i hope i won't have to get to that
decision
now in terms of the covet of course the
whole world is dealing with covet 19
pandemic but but
lebanon has so many other levels of
problems
um starting you know with the security
issues with the
with the economic issues with the
government fallen
and then on top of this the covet 19 so
it is it's been very difficult and you
mentioned the distrust about the vaccine
well this i mean i don't i don't think
the distress is necessarily with the
government per se
but it's more about you know lack of
education about what the vaccine is
and you have all these conspiracy
theories you know that
what if they're putting a chip in us and
you know all these things that you know
are very common now
but more and more i must say since the
first day we got the vaccination until
now
the numbers have tripled and quadrupled
so it's been it's been very good i think
you you got yours could the vaccine end
up being i got yours
a game changer for lebanon could could
we see
the vaccine making a real difference
i think so if anything on on the minimum
level
in terms of at least opening up the
country
boosting a bit the economy the travel of
people going in and out
you know opening again you know shops
and restaurants because we've been on a
lockdown
since mid-january and so many more times
before
so i think that will make a difference
yes it will help for sure
okay well fingers crossed it's been a
pleasure talking to you thank you very
much for being on the show today
thank you so much for having me
and staying in the region and a question
one of our viewers had
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
now that vaccines are beginning to be
widely distributed how long will they
take to actually have an effect on
societies
we've gotten the first tantalizing
answer to this key question now from
israel um at an early stage of vaccine
development its government struck
collaboration deals with companies to
receive
vaccines quickly and at scale
once they were approved in return it
agreed to pay
top dollar but also to share subsequent
data collected by
israel's extensive highly organized
public health care system in effect
the agreements turned the entire country
into a fast-track
giant-scale real-world experiment on the
dynamics of disease spread in a
population
during the largest vaccine campaign in
history
and and i'm happy to say that the
results so far
which were published just a few days ago
um look very good
since the end of december israel has
fully vaccinated close to
one out of every three people in the
country so
they've received both doses um the
impressive numbers on efficacy
from trials indicated that those people
should be well protected just two weeks
after the second shot but that was in
trials
would that also prove true in the real
world well israeli studies comparing
hundreds of thousands of fully
vaccinated adults to those who didn't
get the vaccine
have now shown over 90 percent
effectiveness
in the vaccinated group in other words
they were
many many times less likely to develop
symptomatic covid19 just as the trial
had predicted um they were also over
90 percent less likely to develop severe
disease
and that was regardless of age one of
the authors called the vaccines
incredibly effective in real life um
that's pretty much the most hopeful news
i've heard so far this year
[Music]